thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen we had a very good debate
with cultural ministers this morning on
the innovation potential of Europe's
culture our creative and audio-visual
sectors and how we can ensure they stay
competitive on the world stage these
industries are vital to boost economic
growth job creation and social
development that is why the European
Commission remains determined to
stepping up EU support to them including
through a reinforced creative euro
programme after 2020 I would also like
to work on the resolution that the
Council adopted today on the cultural
dimension of sustainable development
integrating culture into the EU
implementation strategy for the 2030
agenda for sustainable development is
very important culture has a part to
play in working towards all sustainable
development goals and it is only right
that this is recognized and given more
visibility turning to sport we had an
excellent debate on promoting good
governance restoring the integrity of
sport has been a priority for me and I'm
confident that the incoming Commission
will be equally committed to reaching
this goal sport is hugely important for
society but its power is based on trust
people's trust
this means that good governance
principles need to become part of the
structures and daily operations of all
sport organisations we've been working
to support this through the sports fan
of Erasmus plus helping to implement and
improve good good governance in sport
across the EU closely linked to this
issue is the fight against corruption on
which the council also adopted
conclusions today this is another area
where the Commission is committed to
developing effective tools that can help
to protect sport I also welcome the
adoption of conclusions on safeguarding
children sport a very complex issue that
needs to be tackled in a comprehensive
manner I would like to thank the Finnish
presidency for having brought this
sensitive topic to the attention of the
council and finally I'm looking forward
to celebrating the third edition of the
be inclusive we use four
was tonight together with Minister
Hosono handing out awards for nine
outstanding projects this initiative
which I launched in 2017 highlights and
rewards people and organizations using
the power of sport to bring people
together and build communities thank you
very much Thank You commissioner so the
floor is now open for questions
please kindly mention your name and the
media